hortense bêta remercie d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors cette
décision du tribunal judiciaire de
toulouse vous l'avait qualifiée de forte
alors qu'est-ce que cela va changer pour
les supermarchés
un site pour les employés en fait toute
la profession des services et surtout
pour les travailleurs les salariés de la
france
cette décision en fait préserve un droit
acquis qui est celle du repos dominical
donc la décision du tribunal judiciaire
de toulouse prononcé le 30 juillet 2020
est vraiment très forte pour les
salariés qui sont amenés à travailler le
dimanche
notamment les salariés de services de
commerce au détail pour lesquels il
existe une dérivation de travail du
dimanche jusqu'à 13 heures il faut
savoir que la condamnation des enseignes
casino et leader price dans cette
affaire intervient suite à d'un autre de
nous montre de nombreuses infractions
relevées par les inspections du travail
et j'essaie de justice justement pour
pour bien comprendre comment est ce que
le groupe casino faisait concrètement
pour contourner la loi
donc le gros casinos qui connaissait
très bien les infractions à la loi
auxquels elles s'exposaient pour ne pas
faire travailler ses salariés le
dimanche après midi à 13h employés les
agents de service de sociétés avec
lesquelles elle est signée des
prestations de coûts des coûts de
service donc des sociétés de
surveillance de gardiennage qui elle
venait en assistance aux clients des
magasins casino qui ouvraient le
dimanche après 13h en mettant en place
des automates permettant aux clients de
faire leurs achats
alors les surveillants de ces magasins
qui ont pour mission que de surveiller
les biens et les personnes de ses
enseignes et est sollicité de nombreux
soit par les clients qui se retrouvaient
en problématique avec l'utilisation des
caisses automatiques
six de ces en scène et donc se mettaient
à voir la fonction d'hôtesse de caisse
qui n'est pas la leur et qui est
complètement interdite est illégale
alors vous avez parlé de casino leader
price est ce que c'est une pratique
courante de la part des groupes de la
grande distribution
là c'est une pratique qui tente qui tend
à s'étendre en ce moment c'est de dire
que les enseignes des sociétés de ventes
de détail ont tendance en ce moment à
ouvrir après les heures légales en
expliquant qu'ils mettent en place des
automates qui ne nécessite pas
d'intervention humaine
or c'est totalement faux puisque vous
savez quand l automate ne fonctionne pas
il faut une intervention humaine
dernière et les groupes casino avait
trouvé la parade
c'est un complètement illégal je le
redis encore de faire missionner les
jason de surveillance pour faire
fonction d'hôtesse de caisse en même
temps qu'ils étaient surveillants de
supermarché ce qui n'est pas possible
alors casino à lui a décidé de faire
appel de cette décision qu'est ce que
cela vous inspire
de toute façon la condamnation étant
tellement dense et dans lourdes pour les
magasins casino et autre qu'yves autres
enseignes qui voudraient y limiter un
petit peu ces comportements complètement
inégaux ils vont faire appel d'une
décision en référé mais nous attendons
justement pour un oeil au fond sur cette
question pour qu'un juge en cas de
cassation impose de façon définitive est
clair en tout cas positionne cette
décision comme décision de principe pour
ses services de telle sorte que plus
personne n'ait envie de déroger à la loi
comme c'est fait de façon ostentatoire
en ce moment par les enseignes de vente
de détail qui existe un petit peu
partout sur le territoire français quand
vous dites aller au fond de cette
décision ça veut dire qu'il a des
contours qui sont encore pas très clair
pas du tout la décision est très clair
l'état précise elle a ordonné de façon
ferme est assortie d'astreintes de 20000
euros par salarié par dimanche
ce qui n'est pas rien donc non la
décision est très fermes et très clairs
mais comme c'est une décision de référé
il faut qu'on puisse aller au fond pour
discuter aucun juge de fond 10 en
cassation de façon définitive que c'est
complètement illégal de faire travailler
les salariés le dimanche après 13 heures
c'est comme l'indiquent la décision tout
simplement donc les étudiants deviennent
une décision de principe
merci beaucoup hortense betar d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes avocate et représentants de la
branche locale syndicat fo service